so you're getting into data science
where hopefully you're about to make a
really nice salary
but you're looking a few steps ahead as
you should
and you wonder what your long-term
career path
actually looks like keep watching and
we'll discuss that
i'm richard and this is richard undata
[Music]
so this question you would think would
have a totally straightforward answer
and i'm just gonna get the cat out of
the bag up front it doesn't
the first reason for that is that data
science is such a brand new field
it really doesn't have a long history
that we can look back on
and in fact data science didn't really
get started until about 2010
so we're sort of in the process of
writing our own history
and the second reason is that the field
is so incredibly broad
what you end up doing will almost
invariably be guided by
certain principles but from job to job
and from person to person
there is going to be enormous variation
but then you've also got the people who
think we aren't really going to have a
career path
because data science is just going to be
dead in a few years anyway
i already did a video on that
perspective and i'll have it linked
below
but the long and short of it is i
absolutely do not think that's the case
and i think it'll be a completely robust
field in the future
even if it might look a little bit
different rather than talk about the
data science field as a whole though
i want to approach this for more of an
individual level
and look at what you can reasonably
expect your data science career to look
like
over an extended period of time as a
disclaimer i'm not a career counselor or
anything
i'm just a data scientist who makes
videos and has opinions
so by and large take this video as some
hopefully helpful food for thought
some motivation and maybe even a little
bit of entertainment
and then before we get started please
subscribe to my channel and hit the
notification bell so you never miss an
update and then take half a second of
time
to smash the like button because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
lastly i'll have a link to my patreon
account in the description
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over there that would be
massively appreciated as well
alright so i'm going to break this into
three parts the short term
the medium term and the long term and
i'm gonna take the short term to mean
about one to five years
the medium term to mean five to ten
years and then the long term to be ten
plus years
so let's start with the short term here
you've landed that first
internship or job well what now well the
first thing to point out is that the
data science pipeline
can be massively long your work may be
limited to just a specific part of the
process
for a given product or project so you're
not necessarily going to be exposed to
the whole pipeline
immediately or even within your first
year this is an illustration from the
hackernoon blog
of the ai hierarchy of needs and i'm
showing you this because i think it does
an amazing job of illustrating
everything that can go into a data
science product pipeline
and now at first you might just be
isolated to analytics and metrics
with maybe some cleaning here and there
some a b testing or algorithms here and
there
but over time you are going to get to
play with the fun ai
and deep learning stuff as well as gain
a deeper understanding
and appreciation for all the stuff at
the bottom like where data gets
collected
and how it gets moved around and stored
if you don't get exposure to a growing
number of things
you might have to change companies which
in fact
is something that a lot of people do
within their first five years
that exposure is incredibly valuable
experience
and it'll give you a great idea of
things you might potentially want to
specialize in
which is a terrific segue into the fact
that over time
you're going to build your technical
expertise massively
i talk in my video about a data science
study pathway that i recommend
learning sql first and then getting
really good at either
r or python then after the fact you can
go back
and learn enough of the other one of r
or python in order to be dangerous
as well as build your experience with
things like machine learning
and then those of you who've been
following me for a while have probably
heard me before
rattling off lists of programming
languages and big
data technologies sort of making fun of
companies who have unrealistic
expectations
here's what i will say though knowing a
whole bunch of programming languages
and knowing them really well is a
ridiculous proposition for somebody
who's fresh out of school
or somebody who's making a lateral move
into data science for the first time
but over time once you've started doing
data science work in the real world
year after year it will start to become
a little bit more doable
supposing of course you're interested in
expanding your technical capabilities
which you probably should be
if you're in data science in the first
place you're going to start
getting better and better at your
programming language of choice as you
use it to solve more problems
if it's r or python you're going to
start using different packages
and doing things with that language that
previously you had never thought
possible
but also over time you should get the
chance to branch into some new
technologies at the job you're working
at
if not that's probably a giant
shortcoming at your current job
but even if that's not the case when
we're looking over the period of
multiple years
it's not that hard to pick up something
like javascript or julia or
whatever the case may be start learning
it a little bit on the side and maybe
even try a project here there
maybe even at say the two to three year
point if you're thinking about switching
jobs
one of the lenses that you can look at
prospective future
jobs through is the opportunities that
job is going to give you to expand your
technical expertise
but now let's suppose you do stay at the
same company or at the very least you
stick within the same domain
you might be going into that first job
with little to no experience in that
particular domain
and trust me if that happens you are not
going to be the most useful person in
the first few months
but you get over that hump fairly
quickly certainly within six months to a
year
but the amount that you're going to
learn about that particular domain
within five years cannot be understated
whether that's healthcare automotive
finance
whatever that case may be for you you're
going to look back at your first month
when you had weird acronyms
drop on you that you didn't understand
and you're just going to laugh
and you're going to think very
critically about your sponsor's real
world experience
in a way that other colleagues aren't
necessarily going to be able to
and all that is going to make you a much
better data scientist
but also let me use this opportunity to
speak to something that i experienced
that i know others have experienced and
that hopefully you will experience
as well which is that you're going to
see subtly over time
your role is going to shift from more
tactical in nature
to more strategic let me put it this way
maybe you come into your company at
first just to support a specific
product or project maybe you function as
sort of like a code monkey at first
or maybe you find yourself in a large
scrum meeting
and you're just one of a large number of
people who are in there giving updates
on various tasks that are in progress
a cog in a machine if you will overtime
though
you are going to gain significant
independence
and you're going to work on increasingly
unstructured problems
and i think over time your job will look
a lot less like people telling you what
the right problem to solve is
and more like telling you to go find the
right problem to solve and then to go
and solve it
so let's say you're five years into data
science
hopefully by this point your title sort
of reflects that
it might be senior or principal data
scientist
what exactly that's going to be is going
to depend a lot on your specific company
but there's no reason at all you
shouldn't have a pretty decent title by
this point
as well as a handful of generous pay
raises and it's by this point you
probably should have a fairly clear idea
of whether data science
is for you or not maybe it is but only
for so long
it's around this point that if you're
going to make some type of shift in your
role
it could make a lot of sense i've heard
of things like people shifting into
becoming a product owner or manager
or a software engineer now things like
that are obviously going to depend on
your interest and your expertise in the
domain or the technical realms
respectively
but if you're sticking with data science
you could probably become an
organizational subject matter expert by
this point
and what that subject is is totally up
to you
maybe it's our shiny maybe it's natural
language processing
who cares that's on you but i think even
taking these things a step further
you can expect by this point to be
either mentoring people
managing some level of initiative
depending on the size and the scale of
your company
or both there's a good description on
medium by author
jan zowadski on what a typical senior
data scientist
does and does not now again the emphasis
here is not
on what the title of senior data
scientist entails
but rather what your life looks like
after you've accrued a certain amount of
experience
he breaks it down as a data scientist
who has mastered the art of putting
mathematical models into production
as well as someone who builds
well-architected products
it's someone who avoids logical flaws in
the model
takes pride in preparing data correctly
mentors data scientists who are fresh
off the block
but communicates about business
questions to management as well
he says they're not expected to lead
entire teams
but they come up with ideas for new
products and they know the details of
the products they have built
but they're not necessarily experts on
the overall architecture of
all data-driven products that's the
medium term
you're a thought leader not the head guy
in charge of everything
but somebody who has made incredible
strides
and now that brings us to the final
category which is the long term
what does life look like for a person
who's been a data scientist
for more than 10 years besides making a
whole bunch of money
that part is obvious well this part is
going to be highly speculative
because on one hand i'm not there yet
myself
and there's very few people who have
consistently been in data science now
for 10 whole years or more though it is
fair to say that there
are similar roles that have migrated
into data science over time
and that maybe have similar trajectories
that we can look at
to give ourselves an educated guess here
your first natural question might be
what about the c-suite this is from
maryville university in st
louis missouri and they talk about ctos
or chief technology officers
and they break down that some key i.t
areas or network
architecture big data engineering
information security management
security engineering and web software
development
you'll probably dabble with some of
these and many other things
in 10 plus years of data science then
they break down that about
five to ten years of experience you can
apply to a manager or director role
but that at around 15 years or so you're
fair game for a cto role
but ctos aren't the only c-suite role
that's possible for data scientists
there's talk that an increasing number
of cios
are going to need strong knowledge with
data science or to serve as chief data
scientists themselves
that's going to bode really well for
future data scientists
who are trying to get these types of
spots then of course the questions been
floated before about
can a data scientist go all the way and
become a ceo
now there's an article about this topic
that i'll have linked and the short take
was
the chances are pretty slim but it has
happened before
probably more than we even know maybe
the c-suite sounds too ambitious for you
you're not interested in all that well
you can google
director of data science and you'll find
several positions out there
that actually specifically ask for 10
plus years of analytics and data science
experience
i really do think the sky's the limit on
this one
10 years of experience is an incredibly
powerful asset for anybody to have
and if you did the grunt work along the
way to make sure you were growing
at the right things in the right ways
you can get yourself within striking
distance of some incredibly lucrative
positions so hopefully if nothing else
this video gives you some excitement and
some motivation
about what the future of data science
holds for you
now i have to stress again as i have
multiple times throughout this
video your experience may vary
and if your company isn't supporting you
and growing the way that you want to
or it's super unclear what the horizon
of let's say
even a year in the future looks like for
you well that's a big time problem
but data science is an incredibly broad
field with tons of interest in it
that's not going anywhere stick around
in it for a while
and there's no reason to believe it's
not going to pay off for you massively
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please hit the like button
and then leave me a comment down below
and let me know what your career plans
with data science look like
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data